have you guys ever experienced thirst
not having a single drop of water to
drink these people have brothers and
sisters donate towards the water well
and let it be a sadakajali for you for
every single drop like this entire
mankind drinks and animals and trees and
everyone that benefits from this
alcajaria please donate whatever you can
i used to struggle reading the quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app i never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for ios
and android and build your habit with
the quran right now
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters in dear friends
when i came across this video i was
shocked
you guys know that i've done videos
about masala regularly about this
christmas tree and celebrating christmas
et cetera now most of i can maybe just
about get away with it and just say you
know it's a cultural thing it's enough
to do my religion whatever it may be you
can say it may be okay but you know very
consistent of doing every year what
kareem benze benzema done is on a whole
level not another level why is it
brother sisters what he did left masala
as yani if we compare him to what kareem
done we can say it mostly can be the
amino meaning
it's so bad what he's done real madrid
obviously i don't follow football or
whatever goes on et cetera but from what
i know that they won the cup or whatever
it may be the world cup or lethal
whatever i don't follow football i
dislike it's boring yeah so what did he
do what did they do so they all went to
a cathedral in italy and they went and
did the following which you can see on
screen now we need to really understand
and put things into perspective because
we do not understand how disgusting how
vile shirk is if the most evil
heinous crimes on this earth were to be
committed it will not even come close to
what shilk is imagine shirk as the vast
ocean and the most evil is he in his
crime is a droplet the heinous whatever
that can come in your mind it is
millions and billions times worse than
that
this is someone kareem which i went on
this instagram is somebody who
does this with um cupping yeah he's
somebody who's faster than ramadan which
observed he doesn't show his wife which
is commendable etc which you can see
there's some islamic traits there you
can see that he's a clever muslim if he
wasn't we can say you know what he
doesn't know better
he's going and just imagine the
blessings that he have and we call it
blessings we you know allah told us in
the quran that you know just
paraphrasing that you know don't think
that you know the children that you're
given et cetera and don't think allah
yan is pleased with you because you have
these stuff no it can be a curse so he
has those things in his life
they win the cup
now after we win the cup guys you think
they're going to go and thank the lord
thank allah you know thank him singing
about him in his in his worship singing
about in his um uh um singing him out in
his lordship singing about in worship
singing like his names and attributes
and
dedicate be grateful for the blessings
no
what do they do they go and there's two
powerful eyes in the quran i want to
share with you guys please listen
carefully well this is so sad as a
muslim yeah what life the least you can
do is say you know i would not like to
partake in it there are muslim players
without alcohol involved i don't want to
be gambling up i don't want to be [ __ ]
you should run
go to other side of the planet leave it
leave the planet
what does he do look on the screen guys
he goes there and i didn't know who he
was what he looks like i was found on
instagram and i realized he's carrying
one of the cops
he's there greeting them there's nothing
wrong with greeting the people of the
book okay no problem hello how you doing
there's nothing wrong even going inside
the church there's not i've been inside
the church there's nothing wrong with
that they want to do what they do and
even you know some people have the
opinion
you know
that you know if i they would have let
them play pray in the church of the
sahaba unless he said that i feel that
the muslim would take us to some kind of
customs etc
so he goes there and look what they do
guys they go
they leave the trophies there okay not
that we just leaving the trophies there
and then what did they do and he's
carrying one of them he is kareem is
carrying one of them yeah and he goes
and offers it to
the virgin mary or some other virgin
whatever it may be yeah
the heavens and the earth
heavens and the earth who sustains you
who gives you food he's giving you
children he's given you everything and
what you do allah said and on the day of
judgement allah will say o
isa jesus son of may and mary peace be
upon him and his mother did you ever ask
that did you ever ask the people to
worship you and your mother as god
he will answer glory be to you how could
i ever say what i had no right to say
one of the biggest sins in islam is what
to say something about allah said for
himself like what the christians do a
lot of the sun is a part of the trinity
is this that et cetera and that's what
allah is referring to different forms of
christianity here well this is the
catholics now we take
mary as a god not literally but i'll
come to that
if i had said such a thing you would
have certainly know it you know what is
hidden within me but i do not know what
is
uh within you indeed you are alone or no
on
all sin
i never told them anything except what
you ordered me to say worship allah my
lord and your lord and i and i was a
witness over them as long as i remain
among them
but when you took me you were witness
over them and you are witness over all
things and look at this verse this
offering that you're given to this mary
yes this is
yeah you go with an orphanage when
should be thanking allah you're going to
marry a statue whatever it may be and
offering the cup and guess what allah
said all humanity or a lesson is set
forth look what allah says so listen to
it carefully those idols you invoke
besides allah can never create as much
as the fly they cannot create anything
they themselves were created
and a fly even if they all were to come
together for that and if a fly were to
snatch anything away from them they
cannot even retrieve it from the fly how
powerless are those who invoke uh invoke
and those invoked
they have not shown allah the reverence
he deserves surely our lies were
powerful almighty
you are offering this this statue cannot
even benefit from it hear it listen to
it touch it benefit from it neither the
statue can
uh bring benefit to it and there's a
habit for the prophet sallallahu that
allah created certain angels from the
moment they were created till the day of
judgment when the horn will be blown
they will be in prostration and some of
you guys are looking why are you so
angry about it well how can i not be
angry
how can i not be angry do you know what
[ __ ] is do you know how filthy [ __ ] is
everything allah has done for us and
created us you go and give it to a
statue to an idol thank you i would have
been ashamed
i will be loved and these angels these
angels
will rise up on that day they'll rise up
when the or the horn is blown well like
we should hate this action and the
angels when they get up they will say
indeed we haven't worshiped you the way
you deserve to be worshipped
we haven't they've been in prostration
from the moment moment they were created
too the horn was blown and they will say
to allah we did not worship you the way
you deserve and we as a creation allah
gives us everything the food that will
eat the health that we have you go to
the statue and thank you statue the
biggest crime against allah the biggest
crime and indeed hellfire is what is
deserved i'm not saying don't talk to
anyone what i'm saying is this action
this actions
that's what i'm going to say and i hope
this reaches brother kareem i'm sorry if
you you know i'm so sorry you know i
don't care about anybody's feelings etc
if the one who's created me is being
wronged i don't care about anyone's feet
i don't think anyone's hurt or listen
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry we should hate
this action i'm gonna leave that that
one says inshallah may allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala make us among those who live
unto him and die until he inshallah and
protect us from the evils of [ __ ]
so they can benefit in trouble